un jeune homme de 16 ans a été inculpé
aujourd'hui d'homicide volontaire et ce
au bout de sept mois d'enquêté 28
septembre dernier on découvrait en
lorraine le corps de deux petits garçons
le crâne fracassé bernard derty fr3
norel consternation à montigny-lès-metz
le meurtrier présumé d'alexandre et de
cyril trouvé mort le 28 septembre
dernier le visage et le crâne fracassé
par de grosses pierres à cet endroit au
sommet de cette pente au milieu de ses
wagons sncf a été identifié par les
policiers de metz il s'agit d'un jeune
garçon 16 ans et demi il en aura 17 en
juin prochain
il est apprenti cuisinier dans un grand
restaurant de metz c'est à la suite
d'une enquête extrêmement minutieuse que
les srpj après sept mois de travail de
recoupement d'interrogatoire est parvenu
à identifier le meurtrier
il a été interpellé mardi matin et gardé
à vue à l'hôtel de police où il aurait
avoué être l'auteur de ce double meurtre
se trouver quand même on dirait à peu
suffoquée parce que ce module est dense
y attendais pas et comment dirais-je
filet mené dans son travail on peut dire
qu'il avait une conduite irréprochable
que c'est un site et même un exemple
pour tout le monde il était gentil doux
jamais décembre chant pouvait pas y
avait rien qui pouvait se poser comme
quoi ça pouvait lui ai même que dans les
six mois on ne revient pas pu succès
mais il ya ce soir le meurtrier présumé
habiter la même rue que le jeune
alexandre beckrich cette rue v les îlots
sous en septembre dernier ont été
retrouvés morts
les deux jeunes garçons de 8 ans
alexandre et cyril jeune meurtrier qui
était inculpé ce soir et écroué au
quartier des mineurs à la prison de metz
queuleu